what's your name no but we'll we'll
we'll uh yeah what's your name that is
phenomenal no what are you going by on
he's doing nothing bibi's doing nothing
because we'll put that in the thing so
bb is doing something bibi is standing
there with he's got a golf club and he's
bouncing a ping-pong ball on the end of
the golf club uh kyle
is sitting on the couch between uh
maurice and uh
and he's got a little he's got a cup so
can you do anything better with the cup
like put it in your mouth or why i just
feel like it'll be better you just bored
him i'm sorry baby's doing something now
baby's actually doing nothing now i'm
doing nothing okay okay
watch this watch what he's doing
well
well you caught it you moved the cup
was that good it was good it was good it
was hot he didn't catch it with the
butter it was good what's the most viral
video you had i have a video where i did
a 10 cup pyramid like a beer pong like
what's it under i'm gonna have her put
it up right now uh phoebe's doing
nothing
um instagram
bibi's doing nothing on instagram yeah
and how many hits how many clicks did
that one got
100 million 100 million that's almost a
contradiction to this show which is
doing stuff
yeah
oh right we do we're doing stuff bibi's
doing nothing on howie mandel does stuff
would you buy a lou chip bag uh shirt
one left how did you get bbs doing them
left
speak into the mic
any mic that doesn't matter what the
what's the matter with you let's go to
that speaking of the mic not that one
the other one not the other one right
there
no you know what i think
i'm not doing anything here no
that's gonna be my channel maurice isn't
doing anything
sit down mike here's the mic yeah all
right so me and my buddy
we created an account when i was uh back
in like high school
um what the hell are you wearing you
stink
i haven't watched this in a few days
um
why you don't say that to somebody but
he's right next to me howie uh without
the one on the top top top right look at
that wait there's a woman uh shooting a
golf ball off your ass that old lady
isn't that the old lady that was on her
show that's granny
yeah well look at this
oh wow so this was wow 18.
are you okay does anyone play
does anyone play beer pong with you ever
amazing
they shouldn't no but so just for those
that are listening and not watching he's
got pyramids of cups of water on the
table and he's throwing ping pong he's
not missing one no and they're in a
pyramid thing and he's throwing them all
and that's a hundred million views
throwing them one at a time the key is
that you're throwing them are you good
at beer pong i'm not bad
why is that are you being uh you're
being uh trying to be nice so that's 18.
are you canadian so am i where are you
from baby just outside of toronto where
where uh mississauga we're all from
toronto you know everybody's friends
from mississauga that's not a real city
is it you know john can you little guy
talk in the mic please hang out with him
um could you talk in the mic yeah john
uh hung out with him last week did you
how about john have you seen john lately
do you live here do you live in
mississauga no so i live in uh calgary
right now
here for
about a week or so why are you here uh
filming did some stuff with david ross
uh john
uh trying to get some content done
you want to do something with me
i would love to do something it is
amazing what he can do absolutely yeah
but you do sorry i i said no i don't i i
i like you it's like you're a force user
the way you're doing this is
unbelievable show us another one show us
another one so this one it's like beer
pong oh there's i want to see what he
did with granny so this is ross's
grandmother from youtube has got a cup
on her head she's 95 years old and he's
golfing and knocking cups off her head
with a golf ball
wow that's what i said kyle you should
have put the cup somewhere else a bb
would that work
on your butt oh in your body as long as
i can hit them in the head a few times
any aged individual yeah have you ever
gotten a has anything bad ever happened
in the midst of any of these with the
ping pong ball did anybody get injured
yeah
no
so i can i make a suggestion i think we
should do it again kyle come in here
we'll place a cup maybe on like he'll
squat down on all fours and we'll place
a cup on his butt and see if he can make
a ping pong ball you know you're the
only one in this room jackie that wants
to see kyle in all fours
i just feel like no with his pants on
i'm not saying like take off your pants
how far down did she push the tee
before she made that shot i mean there's
a way you could get who is that the
golfer uh
she's a golfer back in calgary
so is that your girlfriend uh she is not
do you have a girlfriend i do not have
are you
are you have a sexual are you
heterosexual yeah you can't ask me no
you can't answer that because you asked
that twice if you had a girlfriend and i
assumed that perhaps he liked me very
close to me
because he's cuddling with you you're
not allowed to ask me you can't ask
there's so many mics i don't know where
to speak i don't i don't do podcasts
you're good um lou so you can't ask that
question no it's inappropriate there's a
lot of stuff you can't do that you do
strike my last question i'm not striking
it i'm gonna leave it because i think
this is a teachable moment oh for you're
talking to bibi
[Applause]
is it really yeah just like
why
how it may be white guys
it's not a learnable moment so
are we doing something wrong caroline
speaking as his former roommate i'll
learn you that
okay
uh have you did you break up with
somebody recently no
i throw ping pong balls into cups yes
say it in their mic i throw ping pong
balls into cups is that your opening
line to women it doesn't work often
it depends what you're referring to as a
ping pong ball or a cop that's right
the trust shot i mean you do have a lot
of attractive people helping you
yeah you just gotta tell them
you're gonna be viral yeah women will
show up for a viral moment right is that
what's happening here can i fling my
balls at your head that's what you say
and they're like sure wow whoa jackie
but she's the only one in this studio
that could get away with that comment
yeah wait a second dudes especially
older dudes cannot say a thing is she
not wearing shoes what the hell is going
on oh my god i i don't know in that clip
by the way we're watching a clip for
those of you who are not watching on
youtube and just listening we're
watching a clip of a very pretty woman
putting stuff on her head without shoes
putting stuff on her head and you are
knocking it off with a is that a golf
ball or a ping-pong ball it's like a
foam ball so that you don't actually
hurt someone in case there's phoebe i'm
impressed with your talents how did you
discover that you had this talent what
made you think that you could do
stuff like this
and even more uh daring than this so
what was it that happened to you
when you were younger that made you
think that this is something that i'd
like to put on a youtube video
when did you decide that this is
something that was important to you to
share with the rest of the world i don't
think he understands the question let me
ask you this bibi you have this ability
to do this
how did you discover that disability was
something that would appeal to me for
example so are you i need to know why
because it's important for people to see
that if they have this gift they too can
find a barefoot woman with a cup on her
head
sorry what was the question
how did you know you had this gift
seriously
i started about 10 years ago i always
wanted to be i thought being an actor or
being on tv was the coolest thing it is
but i do what about being on a podcast
even cooler
um eve like i just i never was
comfortable speaking
and so i was like i'm gonna throw
paintballs into cups
in lieu of speaking
are you a singer oh no can you sing
because not at all no let us i'm a judge
a talent judge sing something what's
your favorite and then
i don't want to do this
it's so uncomfortable are you
uncomfortable
he said he doesn't like talking and lou
is here asking him a hundred questions
because it was the same question jackie
over and over again okay
yes yeah what was the question let's
sing a song what would you like to hear
how we we're gonna sing a duet no i
don't care it's happening to him he's
the guest you haven't should be the
theme to the friendly giant being as
we're all canadians we should no
just
slap that i don't i don't know that i
just keep watching the same video over
and over again because i'm too
uncomfortable to look at him
if you go down to the middle
oh wow yeah that one oh look at that
there's a
who i do visual effects stuff as well so
you can go to the let me see your visual
effect
you do visual effects so are you
actually here
maybe how did you do oh wow oh my god
how did you do that
i know that's a stupid have you done any
commercials and stuff do they hire you
for commercials no i don't know how to
get them to hire me
jason there's an agent here podcast
there's an agent here
jason look at his stuff
this would be good for sports look at
that look at that everything's canadian
explain to me how it's done jackie
what the basketball one i knew tell me
to isolate that image and slow down just
that image right very cool
no am i wrong he does is amazing yeah i
can do
yeah whoa whoa
wow i don't know so we're just going
whoa at videos we're watching on an
audio platform yeah but just take our
word for it we're seeing amazing things
you got to go to his instagram page and
it's bb does nothing on instagram and
everything you see right now he's
golfing a roll of toilet paper and i
think he's going to try to sink it onto
the neck of a bottle the bottom line is
a whole bunch of really cool trick shots
right there on to the neck of a bottle
does that happen
you're watching it whoa he just sliced a
candle in half with a with a card
and i feel like this would be really
good for canada's got talent
no no i'm a judge on canada's got talent
you should come on
i mean
do we get like do i get a lot of
attempts or do i have to make it like
once it's one shot yeah this is this one
well you got no it doesn't have to be
one shot but you got to get something
done in two minutes yeah
it's two minutes you ever do that tick
tock thing where you go live and people
just watch you while you attempt it and
wait to get it in i've done it a couple
times yeah how'd that work out for you
not great okay we we tried we tried
doing a 24-hour live on tick tock 24
hours of you
hitting things with us oh i was just
kind of just sitting there oh 24 hours
live of you just sitting there pretty
much hence the bb does nothing
kind of like what i'm doing now
[Music]